we've been given a new look at house of
the dragon a game of thrones prequel
series in the form of some new images
and information so let's get straight
into it here we have a concerned looking
woman she's princess rhaenyra targaryen
a dragon rider who's one of the house of
dragons royal characters wanting to sit
on the iron throne here's the
kind-hearted king visory's targaryen
father of rhaenyra targaryen here's
allison hightower daughter of sir otto
hightower allison later becomes risery's
second wife this is otto hightower
allison's father and a close ally of
king riseries as his official right hand
man i hope you like flashbacks because
this image of young rhaenyra and young
allison promises will begin in some
backstory on what looks like a young
friendship between these two characters
here is prince demon targaryen this
armour clad fellow is sir christian cole
lord commander of the kingsguard for
king's riseries this is my zarya she
also romances prince daemon and
sometimes goes by the name lady misery
and finally here's princess rhaenys
targaryen with her husband police
violarium all right guys that was just
some quick information regarding some
characters for this tv show their names
and i gotta say the designs for the
characters are looking pretty good i'm
liking what we're seeing here um also
the release date for the tv show was
revealed which is august 21st which i'm
not going to like this is actually
releasing a little sooner than i was
expecting so that is good news and i'm
willing to give this show a shot i'm
looking forward to seeing it even though
season 8 of game of thrones was not good
as we all know but this show is made by
completely different creatives different
people behind this so yeah i'm willing
to give it a shot let me know what you
guys think in the comment section below
what do you think of these new images
that we have seen today and are you guys
excited to see this show let me know in
the comment section below if you haven't
already please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching guys